I do feel that as an entrepreneur what
you are trying to do is something which
which hasn't been created so it's all
about the freshness and how frequently
can you unlearn and learn new things and
then build on on totally diverse areas
and stuff I think the Common Thread
would be the uh the newness and the
ability to learn new things on an
ongoing basis
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
now we're going to go to agriculture
with Amit Sinha the co-founder of unati
a new age fintech powered agritech
platform and his present capacity Amit
is responsible for overseeing all
operations in unati he comes with a rich
academic background having completed his
bachelor's degree in mining engineering
from the Indian Institute of Technology
IIT and he went on to pursue his MBA in
pgdm and marketing from the Indian
Institute of Management throughout the
course of his prolific career Amit has
achieved several milestones and has been
associated with renowned organizations
in senior roles he has previously worked
with Brands such as Infosys prize water
house Coopers bartiertel and 197
Communications he joined paytm where he
served as the Chief Financial Officer
head of HR CEO and business head for
insurance for over four years before
co-founding unati with Ashok Prasad Amit
aims to leverage his rich tease and
Industry experience to scale unathi's
operations and create farmer
entrepreneurs across the country
Amit silha welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you thank you so much for being
here
thanks Michael uh I'm really excited to
have a discussion with you on the
journey and what we have been doing
um I mean your journey is so uh so
interesting and I think this is going to
be such a such a refreshing episode
you've had such an interesting such an
interesting Journey uh from pursuing a
bachelor's degree in mining engineering
from IIT and then an MBA and then
continuing to a variety of senior roles
whether it being in in places like
pricewaterhousecoopers and different
organizations a paytm or your CFO a head
of HR sale and business head for
insurance for four years a co-founding
unati and now looking at Farmer
entrepreneurs so so many different
things to uncover over these 20 minutes
and I have to ask your meat you know if
you look at your career a little bit now
connecting the dots what's been sort of
the common thread for you as you're
looking at all these different Endeavors
that you've been a part of
well I think the the most common thread
is the learning that I've been doing so
uh there has always been something new
to sort of work on to learn and uh and
then sort of deliver something which is
which has not yet been done so
um I I I do feel that as an entrepreneur
what you are trying to do is something
which which hasn't been created so it's
all about the freshness and how
frequently can you unlearn and learn new
things and then build on on totally
diverse areas and stuff I think the
Common Thread would be the uh the
newness and the ability to learn new
things on an ongoing basis
and and where's that coming from it's
not a it's not a trivial concept you've
had such you I mean you you've worked at
at amazing places where where did that
entrepreneurial bug come from for you
so I I think I think it goes back to
where I grew up so in fact I grew up in
a very small Township which was quite
remote
okay in India in eastern India right it
was a it was a mining town where there
were very few people and uh in a way I
would say like was tough and but the
interesting fact was that uh it was not
a uh you know a lack of money but a lack
of access to a lot of things and that is
where I think the whole uh whole uh sort
of uh philosophy of trying to find a way
and getting things done okay and not
stopping at whatever uh obstacles are
thrown at you is something that came and
that and that has sort of kept kept on
through the whole uh whole career whole
personal life and uh my first my first
entrepreneur stint was with the paytm's
parent company way back in 2007 so that
was the time I I started seeing very
closely uh that time in in India you
know the the startup thing hadn't yet
caught on so so aggressively but yeah
but I think yeah we it was the early
days but but lots of fun and lots of
learning there and that is where then I
started full time into Arthur University
way back in 2010 uh with the first
startup that me and my partner had
showed it
wow okay so fintech farmer entrepreneurs
tell me all about it what's happening
there
sure so um you know
agriculture in India is very very
different from anywhere else in the
world okay it's a very small folder
Market okay but the land Building size
is much smaller that you would see
anywhere else in the world so you know
the Indian market is very unique and
perhaps this is the last Frontiers which
hasn't yet been conquered by
digitization okay so uh that brings us
to this segment because this is one area
where uh there is a I I always feel
there is a disproportionate value that
Tech mode brilliant okay because uh
complex value chains you know a large
mass of people relying on this for their
livelihood so whatever impact will will
happen will happen in a very very pretty
Grand scale you know touching millions
and millions of lives okay uh uh it it
it can change the face of Indian
agriculture the thing that can do it
okay so that is that is the excitement
with which we start every day and uh uh
fintech uh as you can understand you
know it's a livelihood thing agriculture
is at the end of the day everything
about livelihood of a mass scale of
farmers so that is where the idea was
how do we sort of on one side digitize
and then we realize that driving the
digitization uh has to be very closely
linked to the financial services that
will be uh offering to the farmers
because that is one of the key drivers
of this industry and that's where a
combination of the uh agree value chain
along with Financial Services while
which inter digitized fintech value
chain is what we are trying to marry and
bring together and deliver services to
the Pharma students
so it sounds like you you've identified
so sort of the market here that is being
severely underserved
wide Gap big opportunity do you have
experience with farming that led you to
to this realization as an entrepreneur I
mean and then there's a bunch of
different opportunities for
entrepreneurs how do you
how did you get your your head and your
heart on on Farmer entrepreneurs I'm
really curious about that sure sure so
you know as I said uh my first
um Venture was in 2010 and this was the
time when we actually started offering
uh B2B Digital Services focused on
Farmer engagement Channel engagement
through a whole host talk
um farmer focused organization so it was
a B2B services from the first thing that
we started and uh we actually stumbled
on it uh quite I would say
accidentally because we were tech tech
uh folks both me and my partner who had
a
um who had a strong thesis that you know
rural India is the place where uh the 3G
services this I am saying in 2010 when
3D was just getting launched and my
partner showcased one of was one of the
receiving 3D Consultants of the country
at that point of time so yeah we had
this stations that 3D is going to make
the the data Super Highway that gets
created through this Advanced income
Services would make a disproportionate
impact yeah while obviously Urban is
there but rural is something where uh
whether to say the puck is moving you
know the clearest story is down the line
that is really the real opportunity
and when we started building up
something there uh we realized that
technique agree is the core value chain
for Rural India for driving rural India
because majority of the forts are
involved in farming on some or the other
way and
that is the core industry that drives
the rural economy so uh that is how we
landed up actually in agreed okay uh at
least I did not have any acne back down
my partner did have his family arms and
stuff where he had seen a lot of
challenges and but I had seen a lot of
challenges in rural India the challenge
of access to various things and that is
something that in fact that the the
digital platforms would be able to solve
one and uh once we started working on it
you know we it was very interesting we
have uh we started going out to Doodle
India started realizing how things are
changing how things are shipping up what
are the farmers problems and uh over the
first four to five years that gave us a
lot of insights you know into now what
is the thing that will really make it
work and we had been running these
services for more than two and a half
million farmers at one point of time now
and like a humongous amount of data
being generated and we be we were very
curious as to what the the data say
really okay while there are a lot of
perceptual things that myths that were
broken when we started seeing the data
or what exactly the farmer wants whom
does he trust you know that is very
important this is a rural economy is
driven by local communities you know so
how what drives those trust who are the
key fulcrum of those trust networks that
get created and those trust networks are
what gave us the learning at that point
of time which is what has formed the
core of what we are building today in
Munna okay so so that is how we ended up
with nothing over uh the last seven to
eight years and in between I had my
extended paytm uh back we I went back to
paytm also at the Forefront of the
financial inclusion and digitization of
the of the whole country so to say and
uh was very closely involved there saw a
lot of things got a lot of learning of
how uh our must feel Financial Services
were adopted by the last denominator of
the super strata people who had never
ever you know had seen a mobile phone at
today in a couple of years have started
making all their payments through
um a mobile phone that penetration the
way it was done was was what gave us the
confidence that I had a similar
Services which are built on that stack
okay of financial services would be very
massively adopted by the farmers and
will start uh we'll start a different
kind of a revolution in the agriculture
exist
what have you identified as really the
low-hanging fruits for
for the farmers in rural India what have
you found to be most useful as you're
going through this digitizing process
the very Basics okay uh farming is a
livelihood as I said livelihood activity
so you would look at anything that gives
you an extra margin either on saving
some cost or getting you extra money
okay and that is where we are focusing
on what we do is uh our leading Services
is to go ahead and offer uh at the very
basic uh fertilizer pesticides and seeds
high quality stuff which now a farmer
normally ends up going miles to K okay
ensuring that those offerings are
delivered through a very strong trust
Network that already exists in rural
India okay so our Focus has been on
digitizing the trust Network that
insists between the farm input retainers
and the farmers and the first level of
purchasers go ahead and help farmers
sell their Farm output to various now uh
you know food processors and all so what
we do is
to our basic Services we go ahead and
using the knowledge that we have
embedded in the platform our technology
course added keeps giving these
recommendations of what to be done on
the platform at one point of time and
based on that we would connect the
farmers to his preferred retainer or
Trader in this area where he can custom
both in terms of sourcing his palm
inputs and in places where he can go
ahead and sell his farm out and during
this process we ensure that he is able
to utilize very simple credit products
and use them to go ahead and fund his
working capital like that so this atom
very very base is what we are doing
trying to embed the Commerce into the
knowledge and the trust Network that
exists for agriculture
and what surprised you about
doing exactly that embedding Commerce to
the to these trust networks and this
digitization process you've mentioned
you've already done this for hundreds of
thousands if not millions of farmers you
saw that your mission statement is to
create five million Farm entrepreneurs
so what have you discovered that perhaps
surprised you maybe about consumer
Behavior or about the different way that
farmers are experiencing the
digitization process what's that what
has that been like for you
so one of the biggest surprise names for
US helped me in the
ease of adoption of the farmers and the
whole value chain the equity value chain
to digital that's a good surprise
that's a very very pleasant surprise you
know a couple of years back uh we went
deep into rural India okay with one of
our potential investors and this is a
very funny story uh you know so
in general India is a conservative
Society okay you won't find many people
dating and you know
um interacting and and everybody had
this you know had this mindset at least
two to three years back when we started
that you know people still are far ahead
away from using the type Edition they
are still experimenting and the funny
part was when we went deep inside the
hinterland what we realized that the
generation of farmers who are now coming
in has totally changed they are no more
the people who are not comfortable with
that all of them all of them were on
digital platforms they were doing
Commerce they were doing payments
everything digitally the only thing that
they did not do was farming digital you
know and when we talked to them what we
realized was
their simple thing was we don't trust a
nameless faceless Organization for our
livelihood thing if we can have an
access to a trusted Network would be
very happy
and you know these these these rural
folks who are there uh typically these
are young guys 30 to 40 years age uh who
have uh who now are much more you know
educated and aware as compared to their
parents for the previous generation of
farmers were
they have everything on their phones
they have the best quality phones
available and they have full detect
activity so the the the
adoption and the speed at which they are
adopting and not only adopting they are
in fact they have been The Guiding
lights for our product development
are one standard thing in the company is
that anybody who joins especially in the
product and Tech teams goes off for a
month visit to various rural markets to
just stay there and understand all the
people what they want in the app you
know so a lot of our features have
actually been built based on what they
have asked for and what what
so it was a very pleasant surprise it
has made our life uh much more I would
say exciting and in a way easier also
that we are getting this uh upfront
feedback from the farmers that this is
what we want this is what we want in our
in our solution
and so if you're looking now three to
five years down the line with your
obviously your passion your excitement
the impact that you're making the
optimism what is the vision that you see
for unati if you're looking three to
five years down the line
do you know what what we believe that in
three to five years time period
we would be able to give this 5 million
Farmers a way of informed decision you
know what we formally believe is that
the farmer themselves are the best judge
of what is needed for them which is a
very very you know localized uh activity
that they are doing based on their local
soil conditions their local weather
conditions their local uh you know
irrigation facilities so
it is at the end of the day our job is
to go ahead and
give these 5 million farmers
all the digital tools and information to
make the best easy
in the context of what they are doing so
for example I'll I'll share a a very
interesting uh scenario that we were
discussing with one of the farmers and
he said that if we can do this then I
would be very happy so for example uh we
were telling him that if you have to go
ahead and Export your fresh produce you
need to not use certain food with the
sites and stuff and his point was Sir I
don't know these okay
can somebody tell me right at the time
of my buying of a particular let's say
chemical or a particular seed that if
you use this this then this is the
impact that will be there on my
potential earning because I will not be
able to then export because there is a
pesticide residue that comes out of this
chemical that is now this this Insight
was very powerful like this is around
which our platform is evolving and
building up that we should be able to
give farmer the right choices at the
time of
his need
that if you do this then this is the
impact that will happen on your future
earnings and then leave it for him to
decide whether he wants to do it or not
okay rather than being a prescription so
any three to five years we expect 5
million Farmers to use our platform and
significantly build on the knowledge
that comes from this Collective platform
for uh what should be done in their
particular feedback how it should be
done so that they can go as as
Advanced knowledgeable farming as a
let's say a thousand hectare Farmers
versus water 180 Farmers so the the
purpose of our platform is to fully
democratize the access to the services
that till now has been accessible only
to the really large Farmers but also to
the small and the media path
that's very very cool and it sounds um
it sounds like such a healthy
entrepreneurial process from identifying
an interesting Gap in the market to
identifying you know a lot of
opportunity to make a significant
difference in people's lives finding
optimistically huge willingness for
adoption and learning about consumer
Behavior that's driving this growth in a
very healthy way and then continuing
with that Vision to continue building it
and scaling it and and so I I mean I
really want to thank you for coming here
for these 20 short but but insightful
minutes and leaving me with a lot more
questions to ask but but nonetheless a
very very interesting journey and I
really want to thank you for the time
and the energy and the impact that
you're making and um best of luck with
unati and with all the other endeavors
you'll be a part of and stay safe and
stay healthy thanks thanks Michael it
was a pleasure talking to you and
answering your question thanks so much
for having me here thank you thank you
very very much thanks